now it's time to turn our eyes to last
night's episode of global survivor where
just when you thought having no rice and
limited supplies was hellish enough a
blindfolded immunity challenge made it
oh so much worse uh yeah and while
wednesday night's immunity challenge
left many with bumps and bruises the
real kicker of the episode was the fact
that beware advantages and secret
phrases are back and mike from the vati
tribe was the first to discover the
immunity idol
it's really like looking for a needle in
a haystack
[Music]
it's incredible i found the idol oh my
god you know it's a first i i can't
believe one of my buckle this item
beware advance if you take it
it's yours and you must
oh i must do what i said otherwise
leave it something in me said don't
leave it i came to this game to say go
big or go home and i'm going big how bad
could it be they found a three-way
shared immunity idol each tribe has one
but in order for your idol to have power
the other two idols must be also be
found
here's how you will know at the next
immunity challenge you must say a secret
phrase in front of the other players so
my phrase is there is such grace in a
game of soccer
it makes me cry i don't like soccer
matter of fact when i coach my football
teams i told my kids it wasn't even a
sport
but i will cry for soccer in this
instance never again once all three
phrases have been set then all three
idols have power but until then you
cannot vote at
oh you can't afford travel county
i found an idol but it lose my vote so
there's a blessing and there's a curse
and now we are joined with our special
survivor correspondent and season 41
winner erica kasoopenin hey erica hi
morgan hi braz it's great to be back to
chat all things survivor look at you
over there all by yourself on an island
some might say does that feel familiar
it's like i'm back on exile island
all right we gotta talk about mike
finding that beware advantage i mean you
know a little something about finding an
advantage uh what was going through his
mind do you think
yeah i mean i had the pleasure of
finding an advantage on my season and as
a survivor super fan it's a dream come
true to find an advantage and in the
game you know that an advantage in the
woods normally means you're going to get
some power something good is going to
happen but
mike found a beware advantage which
means that there could be something good
that happens but he probably has to take
some risk and there's some sacrifice in
order to make something good happen yeah
okay but then we have to discuss what
happened after mike found the idol so he
decided to hide the idol and tell a
couple of his closest allies jenny and
daniel but why do i feel like that was a
big mistake
well especially considering it took him
ages to rediscover his idol after he
hit it only for daniel to go and blab
about it to chanel and i think that with
advantages it's one of those things
where you watch the show and you're
screaming at the tv because you don't
want anybody to be telling anybody else
about their advantages advantages are
power but when you tell somebody else
about where an advantage lies that you
have it how an advantage works now
you're giving other people power in the
game and i think that daniel said it
correctly when he said now that he knows
about mike's advantage he has power
without the penalty yeah screaming at
the tv is what makes watching survivor
so much fun all right what i love so
much about last night's episode is that
we really got to know about a few more
of the castaways on a more personal
level especially hai who shared that he
was vegan and acknowledged that he
needed to eat meat in order to sustain
himself on the island yeah omar also
opened up about his muslim faith and how
his real life values will impact the
game so erica i want to get your take on
hai and omar's remarks and their candor
i think that this is another one of
those things that you love about
watching survivor because you get to
know all of these different people and
it reminds the audience that these
aren't people who are just out there
playing chess these are people who have
their own values their own belief system
they have their lives outside of the
game and their game decisions also rely
on who they are as people and you even
see someone like omar who says that he's
going to be doing his prayer daily and
trying to warn his tribe i'm not going
to be searching for something in the
woods i'm legitimately just doing my
prayers and i think this adds this other
element where these people have to
really reconcile between being players
and playing this deceitful game and
maintaining what their real life values
are all right now circling back to the
blindfolded immunity immunity challenge
the the taku tribe ended up losing which
meant that they would be going off to
tribal council and despite using her
shot in the dark mariah was sent home
erica walk us through what was really
almost an identical tribal council from
last week
i think similar to what happened with
zach who was voted out last week mariah
had the right read on the situation she
knew it was going to be her that was
going home so she decided to play her
shot in the dark and i think what's so
fun about this season is yes the shot in
the dark was introduced when i played
survivor 41 and now we see this whole
other group of people using that same
advantage and they're doing it totally
differently so i'm excited to see what's
next yeah definitely now before mariah
had her torch snuffed by jeff
she opened up to her tribe mates about
her brother and how he was the first
healthcare worker to die of covid
in the united states i mean that was
just such a big revelation she also
revealed that she still hadn't had
closure on the tragedy but planned on
burying her necklace with his face on it
somewhere on the island
yes and i actually spoke to her just
moments ago about that specifically and
truly i got choked up speaking to her
because she didn't end up burying the
necklace and she actually wore the
necklace during the interview and it
seems like being on survivor gave her a
totally different perspective she
doesn't want to bury her brother's
necklace she doesn't want to close that
book and to stop talking about him
instead she wants to keep celebrating
him she wants to be able to honor him
and i think by going on the show and
telling her story now everybody watching
gets to honor her brother too